oh if you stop at 50 i mean that's a
no-brainer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got to take that it's just a
platform interview with the vampire
right it's the same [ __ ] yeah
you're basically a vampire yeah
well you don't drink not man that was a
deep-ass question to us yeah that really
rattles to start a whole new podcast i'm
gonna be thinking about that on the
planet grocery store bagger really got
me
[Laughter]
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
oh i'm in town i'm doing set tonight you
know how it works daddy yeah you know my
schedule bro
yeah you know my schedule dog i know
your schedule a lot we have a lot of the
same schedule you know dude if you're if
you're if your uh wedding is in two
weeks yeah
you're doing show tomorrow right but
you're gonna do it right right right i
am i actually talked to her and
i'll do the show also um
we got these dudes they're on it
everyone knows who they are
make sure everybody's [ __ ]
comfortable and we're all ready to go
yeah we're good everyone has drinkies
screaming cold diet coke over here i'm
set and i want to say as a fat guy who's
done a bunch of pods where it's not well
the guest doesn't have a desk i
appreciate this couch couch is nice i
can slide it back a little bit it's nice
yeah
i mean our fan base gonna be familiar
with you but if they're not
these are two of my favorite human
beings in comedy thank you the pod are
you garbage the most unique podcast in
all the land pretty stressful it's just
[ __ ] but you guys actually have a
kind of a thing to do on youtube you
know when he compliments us he's scary i
know he does it but it's it's foley and
kevin from ru garbagemen all the way
from new york thanks for having us
thanks for having me this is the first
time meeting chris yeah yeah you know
what's crazy is whenever i meet because
i'm from new jersey and like whenever i
meet i always forget that people
with like your energy sure i feel so
good like i feel so
like oh yeah these people cause like you
guys are obviously from the [ __ ] east
coast oh
[Applause]
i i love it like whenever i meet i'm
like oh yeah [ __ ] that's right yep
that's a whole area because in la you
don't really you don't you don't run
into guys with this vibe you really
don't guys over two hundred pounds you
can say yeah
guys who don't have body dysmorphic yeah
that's no i haven't seen two guys as
ugly as you
know
it's refreshing chris is like you guys
hear more man you guys are ugly yeah i
mean your voices and your cadence and
your [ __ ] your your energy
100 and the reason i love these guys
when i did their pod i i was aware
because tim timmy dillon who's a mutual
friend of ours did you pod and then when
i was going to lady i'm sorry going to
new york do all the promo uh for my
special
the every co every big comic every comic
in new york was like you have to do all
your garbage every every single one i
was like you know i'm you know you never
know people are [ __ ] weird but and i
was like are they cool and everyone's
like the best yeah they haven't they
haven't gone yeah they've been able to
trick everybody so far you know
hollywood we can't go hollywood i can't
go jersey what are you nuts yeah yeah
yeah you guys are getting there though
man
things are going well we had you know we
took an escalade here yeah sure nice i
was gonna send you carson i know but
that's also like how trashy i am i'm
like i can't he's gonna send car service
i can't do that you're like no man we'll
just uber yeah please we're helping you
don't worry we'll walk i'll tell you
does the l train run out here i'll take
that we pull up in a limo we're both
sitting in the front seat
a couple of drivers in the back yeah
you take a load off
you relax back down don't worry
i brought my passport that's how i
didn't know where we were
you said calabasas i'm thinking it's
going to be cloud that they're going to
be security gates and this thing
calabasas sounds exotic oh man
rolled by a 7-eleven i was like okay
yeah big goal
get my babies you know i'm garbage i get
a big gulp every single day man i like
how you have three drinks too that's
awesome oh yeah oh dude theo who's not
here today uh shout out to theo he
called me he told me this one legit
concern because yesterday you know when
i do my shows i drink man
he's like dude i know he joked over a
joke around about intervention
he's like but for you he's dead serious
and this is coming from theaters but for
you to drink on most the shows it's
concerning and he goes because i've been
i've been there man you're drinking to
get through it because you hate it i was
like
oh no no you don't don't you love it i
absolutely love it
i absolutely love it dude i have a drink
to celebrate yeah that's where we're
different what do we do with the rest of
the day though like have you already i
assume you worked out this morning right
right right
you wake up you wake up too early 5 30.
whoa five times later that yeah i know
even with kids
yeah you look more tired than me you get
i fee i feel great bro and also the key
is i'm not drinking that's the key the
key is i'm just i got my coffee on my
water i'm chilling right i'm gonna drink
it behind cause you got three you got a
diet coke a coffee
hydrated it's crazy
and then that's just redlining
constantly yeah yeah yeah i got three
shows and you don't and you don't really
well you go to bed early a lot though
sometimes yeah if i'm not doing
something i'm in a bad route 9 30 9 30.
dude kristen
she was like please come into bed early
tonight and just sleep
and i was like i don't want to i said we
were i was like let's watch murder shows
you know you watch murder documentaries
yeah we're talking like like actual docs
or we're talking about christopher dunch
you know the [ __ ] uh surgeon who they
made a show about it dr death joshua
jackson plays it but then i watched the
whole [ __ ] thing i heard the podcast
already i watched a whole [ __ ] thing
on doctor death and then at the end it
was like would you also like the real
documentary about it and i'm like yeah
show me the [ __ ] documentary first
joshua jackson do the [ __ ] thing
i watch all eight episodes and now i
gotta now i want to see the real thing i
[ __ ] would have never watched joshua
jackson but you're a night owl you're
right so she was she was like let's
watch murder shows there's a christopher
dunge thing on she was like okay she
comes down
and then like after 10 minutes she's
like i'm gonna go back upstairs i'm like
you [ __ ] trick me i'm i'm so involved
yeah i just have to finish it dude she
goes up she's like please just this one
time
go come upstairs and watch with me but
what's early
11. yeah why can't you watch it up and
you got the tv up in the room right i
tell you what 11 what are you a vampire
i'll tell you what man
what are you steve aoki what are you a
dj
sleeping like dead
i'm dead 12 yeah well no but like he did
he three hours of sleep don't stop no i
sleep i sleep long enough but i just go
to sleep late but anyway this is getting
derailed my point is i i i i the bet is
for sleeping and and [ __ ] mostly just
sleeping but [ __ ] yeah sometimes but
like i don't want to like [ __ ] like she
wants to like she orders food she's like
can we eat in the bed i'm like [ __ ] no
she got like
nah that's what i thought you guys all
did out here you all laid in like huge
triple king-sized bed and yeah burritos
yeah you'd be right with like white
comforters yeah pillows everywhere
that's his idea of success
[Laughter]
that sounds nice
but but i don't want to like i don't
know i i very much delineate what i plus
we have like a great room downstairs and
i'm like so i'm like all right i'll do
it so i go up and we're it's 11. this is
early for me to be in bed so i go up
we start watching the thing and i pass
the [ __ ] out and then i wake up the next
morning and she dude she's already
looking at me and she's like we got nine
hours of sleep and i'm like i didn't
want this yeah and then i say it now i
know i know i know it's gonna get early
and early i know next thing you know
you're eating dinner at three o'clock i
know
six you
are you do you guys have uh ladies
married yeah i'm married married kiddos
no not yet we got married right before
the pandemic because you're young how
y'all i'm 36 46. okay yeah you're 46 you
like you guys literally look yeah the
same age yeah yeah yeah that's what i've
heard i've seen the youtube comments
yeah they they agree with you as well no
no no i mean they look he's jewelry yeah
that's the perfect combination maybe i'm
just off i don't know but you guys look
like 28 30 right i would say i would say
young i would say early 30s i've also
been drinking since april
this guy's on 15 shots of espresso
hey you look
it's not gay out here dude but no
or anything i got a couple grapes but a
couple though i got more he's got a
great head of hair too that really yeah
that really sells him he's got a great
brother's hand
the pandemic dude yeah i was like
holding tight till the pandemic and then
then what are you talking about
i was doing all right
keeps.com prone coach it might help yep
yeah i haven't on it dude i'm on i'm on
the [ __ ] i'm on the g i'm on the uh
minoxidil and then i do air support do
the pill that's what i call it is it not
helping i call out the air support yeah
bring it bring in the
heavy artillery
how long have you been on it years i
started in like my early 12 mid twenties
it started like i started getting the
runways
financial strategies you're a
finasterider i always forget what it's
called and i take it yeah because just
in case you take it i've been taking it
because they're like you got to take it
i'm like you do wow that's why that's
good though like if you you i should
have started got it or that's what i'm
saying but i met his dad the other day
and the laugh actually his dad [ __ ]
how would you like 70 80 yeah
yeah yeah full of all silver fox just
down to here that's a man who
appreciates his hair he doesn't want to
lose it yeah you lose it
yeah maybe
right i'm happy we got successful like
this year i'm like i'm married starting
to make a couple of bucks i'm like
everybody can suck my dick yeah
i love that
maybe it'd be sweet once you make like a
million bucks just [ __ ] go bald
i got a couple of two years left until i
got a really it's weird when you guys
hang on to it some guys but but some
like here's my thing can i say this
please yeah with your luxurious [ __ ]
hair please please here i'm also i'm
also 900 pounds i have my crosses to
bear
hey hey you're 450. okay i'm not saying
this because i love you it works and it
did you say you said why don't they just
uh buzz it bruce willis rocked that for
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] 20. that's what i'm
just going to keep this is long for me
i'm just going to keep going shorter and
shorter and shorter you know what i mean
yeah there aren't guys i love you not
bruce willis the horrible yeah yeah yeah
you know die hard
this guy's talking crazy
tough guy
dude i don't get like uh my boy brian
kellen struggles with his hair i'm like
dude get a
wig it's 20 22. it's a long one a long
one yeah
it doesn't though if you get close it
looks like a baby ostrich
but what i think about like brian's got
a good head
like he could just go bald
yeah no but i always say the pieces of
me are very ugly
but when you throw them all together
somehow it works dude i don't know what
it is
nobody nobody being born would be like
ooh that's the nose i want sure yeah
that's the mouth that's the eyes or the
knob hey chris i know dude if fans are
enjoying this episode with are you
garbage boys it's a great episode it's
good it ain't patreon daddy no it's not
and last time on our patreon patreon.com
catsplus plus uh we uh had our brothers
on
we had our brothers on and theo was on
and then theo will also be on the next
patreon version the gang is back yeah
the gang's back um we try to make sure
steal's on all the patreon so the
patreon's popping man patreon.com
catsplus and uh sign up you also get the
uh if you sign up now you get all the
other patreon exclusive episodes that we
have backlogged and then you also get
all the free episodes ad free dude it's
some say it's the best patreon ever well
we certainly do you and i do we do yeah
and uh and you know we're trying to make
it so it's more bang for your buck
that's really what it is a lot of
content dude get the patreon
let's take a little break from chat with
our boys from are you garbage chris
because dude you and i don't have this
problem we really don't but two out of
three bros will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 30 35
there's more than 50 million men in the
u.s that suffer from male pattern bald
does that's 50
50 ml 50 million a lot of bros losing
their hair and that's why our friends at
keeps offers a simple affordable stress
free way to keep your hair 24 7 care and
support you meet with a doctor virtually
all right it's low cost treatments start
at just ten dollars a month okay see i
would think that that would be 14 000 a
month it's fair
what was it 10
a month dude affordable yes keeps has
everything your hair needs delivered
straight to your door discreet little
package nobody has to know you're doing
this proven results remember prevention
is prevention yeah that's interesting
that's what i do yes yeah treatment can
take four to six months see results so
act right now if you're ready take
action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash cats to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's keeps.com cats to get your first
month free k-e-e-p-s dot com
ats
chris i know you're a big ufc fan dude
yeah i like the ufc i've been getting
into it you know what's been helping
draftkings oh because you're making
money while you're watching yeah it's
like watching passively is nice but why
not make a little coin ah you're so
right daddy and listen ufc 275 is this
saturday and our friends at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner ufc has a heavyweight offer this
weekend's
fights with a special parlay for all the
listeners and viewers of king of the
sting they took my picks my picks are
yiri shevchenko and wayleigh all right
you bet the three of them you do a
parlay they boost your odds bro they
boost your odds just head to the app
right now into the ufc page to check out
the shop picks bet on it and ride along
with your thick friend here right now
all customers can place the same game
parlay for saturday's fight and if it
hits you double your winnings dude
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code kats new
customers can throw down five dollars on
ufc 275 and get 150 dollars in free bets
instantly free money do it do that free
that's code cats k-a-t-s this saturday
at draftkings sports book the official
sports betting partner of ufc minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details do you guys
you guys feel with not even more
successful any pressure to look a
certain way change your vibes well we
it's a good question i mean we were
also like very
poor i think like i made like nineteen
thousand dollars in like you know twenty
twenty or what was your wife balling she
was doing all right she was definitely
paying the bills what did she do uh she
just works in marketing oh okay yeah
yeah really she has a legit job she's a
legit job right so like she was like
paying the bills and everything awesome
uh
and then yeah we kind of she actually
gave us the money to open the studio
because i was like i didn't have the
money and i was going to get it from a
my boy's a dominican loan shark hell
yeah and he was like i want 10 percent
of it moving forward
and i was like all right i'm going to do
it and my wife's like take the money
yeah
all right yeah she's she's not going to
have so i'm saying what are you doing
sounds like a shadier deal the dominican
[ __ ] long-term or your wife i know we
currently have the yakuza looking
forward
but i do looking back i would that guy
would my buddy would have been making
[ __ ] i would have owed him 10 of our
garbage sounds like a moving forward
yeah that's not a guy you cross either
dominican london dominican and new york
no no but then your your wife believed
in the uh she did she was like i think
it's fun and like we were starting to
cook a little bit you know get some
traction and then she was like just
[ __ ] take the money and open up the
studio and then how's how's the road
life now you guys because it usually
starts with you know you guys got passed
at the seller and stuff like wait hold
on how long have you guys been doing
stand up like hard 15 years yeah i'm
probably like 12. so
15. so this is the thing so this is the
thing like
obviously i know you guys are stand-ups
but the to to have that
under your belt yeah do you know what
i'm saying you have this
yeah dude it's so killer dude oh that's
[ __ ] awesome i'm happy for you guys
thank you
that's what we get like because our live
shows we don't do live pods we'll go out
like me and him co-headline and then we
close out the last like 20-25 minutes
together like [ __ ] around with the
crowds they asked us their garbage
questions perfect because we should suck
yeah live pods schultz actually told me
schultz is like i'm like yeah we're
gonna do live parties like live pods are
for people who can't do stand up he's
like you're [ __ ] new york city
100
and we can't compare it to you know we
don't we we did minor road things yeah i
was like a road feature a little bit
like you know and i mainly worked in the
city hosting uh and we can't really
compare to what it was like to go out by
ourselves but going out together
it's [ __ ] the experiences you guys
are boring we bring our boys
to open our producer and we just write
it down
no it's exciting
i
you work hard and you've worked hard but
[ __ ] god damn it like it's like
what's that [ __ ] saying where luck
meets preparation or what the [ __ ] luck
is preparation and
it's [ __ ] something whatever the [ __ ]
it is
and then it took the one thing that
popped and now people are gonna know how
funny you are as an individual and as a
stand-up it all is awesome dude but then
it's also obviously you guys have thank
you that means a lot thank you yeah you
guys have the chops but then also
the reason why i think you guys are
blown up right now is because you're two
solid people oh no you guys are actually
good people thank you man yeah that's
how everybody [ __ ] me like every i'm
telling you you name a new york comic
every single one is like you have to do
that show have to do that show i just
like having somebody i know next to me
on the plane so i don't feel awkward
again
[Applause]
it's not easy 28 and a half you know
what i mean
our producer shout out to toby
he unfortunately gets placed next to him
he's the buffer
for
whatever and i'm like yeah it's like a
[ __ ] uh he's that's a real we're all
like-minded goofing around it's fun
it's like a tom selleck movie where he's
sitting in the seat the other guy yeah
on the poster
dude dude i turned around the one that
we were on a plane flying [ __ ]
somewhere and i turn around and go
he's in the aisle like his head is in
the middle of the aisle just hanging out
i i had a there was a learning curve
involved in that i always thought as a
fat guy you want the window never they
[ __ ] you in the window because they
don't let that thing come up yeah and i
reach back i dig around
try to find like a like a dead man
switch back there yeah but you always go
aisle because then once we take off you
lift that up and pop a check out there
oh
that time it's tough and sometimes those
those flights get real aggressive with
that part yeah the car i know i'm there
then you're fighting for the elbow space
if you're the island you just have that
with some guy fighting for the eye
the way out here i fought with him for
[ __ ] five hours in my head and i'm
like i might [ __ ] if he says
something i'm like we're gonna get this
is this like that that's how angry it
was it was like duct tape dude it was
like a trench
for the elbows for the knees
and then at the end i was like playing
just like a stupid game like on the
screen just like killing time was
playing like [ __ ] tic-tac-toe or
something he's like hey you want to
borrow my [ __ ] nintendo switch or
whatever oh you are a nice guy
playing the games on the back of your
seat on an airplane
battleship and we were using the uh what
to do with an emergency cards to block
so we couldn't see
do they have that first class they have
that stuff up there no no they give you
the actual board game
you get your own battleship actually
that is the thing we have level seven
we're now flying first this was our last
a little bit our last economy flight was
out here and back and then from here on
out all the tickets but we really can't
afford it technically yeah but i gotta
buy like three years in advance you know
anymore yeah using miles but it's all
you know it's the optics of it too yeah
but bet on yourself you only make more
money so that's good well it's also like
we're fortunate that the patreon does
very well so it's like you're patrons
you know [ __ ]
it's like free money it's like drug
dealer money you know what i mean we
don't use our mouth poor people don't
use their miles but we save them you
save it for like a once in a lifetime
vacation
orlando yeah yeah i'm using the
uh all right nick let's get to it so do
you guys know the show where it's the
fans submit they submit styles honestly
still don't know how their show works
not a fan of the program
uh we actually asked our fans or we had
a number of fans who want to find out if
they're garbage
hilarious
oh look at this little dude hey what's
up team this thing the wing and the are
you garbage team
i've got one for you so i was in jail in
2012 this guy's classy right away
in that time i learned how to make a lot
of food some spread some dishes well uh
sweet and sour chicken hooch
all this stuff and uh now 10 years later
i'm married with the kid i still make
those dishes at home i still serve them
to my son
my favorite is a chili chili pickle
spread it's a basically ramen noodle
with chili and pickle all wrapped up in
a tortilla yeah you're not in prison
yeah
really good
sounds awful does that make me garbage
[Laughter]
am i garbage oh that's great that's
fantastic
this is an easy one huh fellas yeah i
mean you know making jailhouse meals
even though you've been out ten years
yeah for your family that's wild it
honestly sounds that sounds like it
would be so good sounds disgusting no
dude you're oh yeah it sounds all right
yeah the chili ramen burrito hey come on
all the things that i like i'm gonna get
a dui after this
ramen
burrito
you like ramen
not really all right ramen noodles you
like chili hey can can i say something
hopefully it doesn't get my brother in
trouble when we were kids we had you
know we grew up poor we had ramen
noodles and then ice ice put extra
flavoring in it yeah and my brother goes
you know that's chinese sweat they make
that chinese sweat i never ate it again
my dad
that's is that racist i mean well he was
what five so [ __ ] it yeah you can be
racist when you're fighting because
that's chinese [ __ ] i was right when
i was nine i was i was out of the local
clan
hey guys
um
where was the [ __ ] thing uh my dad i
have a story like that my dad told me i
used to love those neutral green bars
you remember those neutrals oh yeah yeah
yeah the neutral green
snickers but yeah and i yeah i know so i
i would eat them all the time and then i
said hey hey dad how come you never eat
these nutri grain bars and they say he
literally just threw it out he said oh
they actually make your butt fat and i
never ate one again dude it's just not
true i still don't need them because
like that's some kind of fun
yeah i've had ramen since i was six and
i still think he's chinese sweat
that chinese sweater is good though bro
yeah it's fantastic it's awesome that's
great ramen is something too that you
forget about and then you're like oh
yeah i could get ramen and then you go
get ramen and you're like why don't i
ever think of it
a because it's so unhealthy you ever
looked at the nutrition facts
on you guys but it is ramen is so
unhealthy yeah that's why it's good
ramen burrito and what was it chili and
pickles uh
he's garbage yeah that's garbage garbage
behavior yeah that's garbage behavior
for sure but it sounds good the only
thing i would say with uh with this
gentleman is um
if you if he maybe like elevated the
ingredients because i would assume
in uh
trader joe's instead of the commissary
you know the farmer's market's probably
not the best in there i would assume so
as long as he's getting like good stuff
and putting it i could see the
combination but
it would be hilarious if there was a
farmer's market in prison
how's the produce today yeah
the tomatoes right
yeah i don't know man you gotta get out
of that that's a tough one yeah that's
yeah he was in jail for how long did he
say i think he said 10 years i think he
said he was out 10 he's been out
i forget ten years but still he's still
hiding like [ __ ] in his ass well you
haven't been in there you haven't been
in there a long time to become like a
culinary expert you know what i mean
like yeah
it really depends
how
true to the script he's keeping these
recipes like i said if he if he's
getting different ingredients and doing
it a little bit better than what he has
in there but if he's putting like
[ __ ] shampoo in it like you know
the secret ingredient is a little
toothpaste yeah it's not good to be
feeding your kid that yeah right you
have his date night's hooch that he's
been making for three weeks with his
wife get some hooch over here baby all
right kids nobody flushed the toilet for
a couple hours
i got a fresh batch in there
what's this lady wanting
that door
one we're closed
i think it's a rain camp when i was 14 i
would steal my brother's weed after he
would go to work he was 17 and steal
just little pinches at a time me and my
friends would smoke it get high and be
so scared when you come home from work
paranoid garbage for stealing my
brother's weed
she did it so quick that's good yeah i
like when they're quick and [ __ ] yeah
yeah very well
i mean who didn't feel who didn't steal
someone's we who didn't pinch a bag of
wheat at some point you got it
i like how she smoked weed and then was
so scared that her brother was gonna
find out i was like she was just from
the wheat yeah that's the weird thing
talking about
the guy who made the sandwich be like i
don't know why i keep [ __ ] myself
i guess most people do it i didn't steal
weed we weren't big weed guys growing up
my brother had a convertible mustang and
the new game boy colored came out and i
stole his mustang when i was 13 and
drove
to toys r us when you were how old i was
13. it was a toy mustang yeah uh no no
actual muscle you were 13. you think you
stole those power wheels
i stole his car it was all like you know
neighborhood
driving i mean
nintendo
i want a red nintendo uh game boy wow
yeah that's grand theft auto
[Laughter]
he also talks really a tight mullet
right there he's in a hot tub or is that
a stand-alone oh garbage gas cat's crew
what do you think old tank turn it into
a pool
king's king
garbage recycling sore or snore well
wear glasses anything's classy remember
that
chin say something
swinging
ready to go
yeah he was out there for a while let's
take knight
team lukewarm water sucks we've seen
that a bunch people cause like we talk
about above ground pools versus ground
pools versus like a stand-alone hot tub
and that a lot of that [ __ ] and a lot of
people in the country have these like
horse tanks or whatever that they then
just turn into like above ground pools
for like 80 bucks the only thing that
makes that completely challenging i kind
of get it's kitschy it'd be fun i get it
if you have kids it's like a one-off
thing i should put some [ __ ] tiki
torches around that though sure you can
make it work that's what i'm saying yeah
it can be like it can be fun and wacky
the back of a pickup is fun when people
put tarps in there but you're just
basically [ __ ] it's like a chick with
glasses and a hat on you're just
disguising how ugly it really is you
know what i mean it's like we know what
you really look like you're not funky
yeah
it's not an infinitive you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
stop with this [ __ ] you know girls this
is a prescription
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the only thing
that makes that classy if he's sitting
in a if it's a big thing of ice right
that's what that's like an ice bath
that's an athlete i mean it looks like
he's got a nice piece of property i see
a palm tree yeah yeah it looks like he's
got a little bit
is that florida what do you think about
you do that right ice bath yeah yeah
i'll do ice bath you got that out there
my six-year-old does ice bath
yeah he saw a thing on tom brady's
obsessed with tom brady it's very
strange where do you do it in your bath
what's up where do you do the ice no we
have a he stole the car
you have a nice tub yeah oh you have one
you have one like cook like running at
all times not all times but he wants to
go in we do it you make it freezing or
it's always freezing no we make it for
you dumping ice cream get the water
circulating you wouldn't expect i would
expect that he would have that back
there i would expect he does it i
wouldn't necessarily expect you to
actually have one just like a trough you
know i got it yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then yeah i don't really know what hot
cold hot coal you have you have a hot
tub at the house yes sauna toast i would
assume you have a hot dog no sauna hot
tub really no sauna uh-uh i'm shocked
that's not oh my god logan's a sonica
i'm not a sonic hot tub connected to the
pool yes
okay
going down to the pool there's a
waterfall yes okay you guys got water
for him
it's actually an ordinance you have to
have a waterfall you're keeping up with
the joneses try keeping up with the
kardashians it's exhausting do you have
a pool i hope oh yeah i get a pool and a
hot tub is connected to it yeah yeah and
the place in the place you're building
you put in a pool i'm gonna put in a
pool yeah with a hot tub yeah nice yeah
but you guys like in new york like
i would never nobody has no no no no
yeah the vanderbilts yeah yeah it's like
you're getting the pool in new york
would cost you 14 million dollars to
have the land yeah
yeah i mean most hotels don't even have
pools there's like four rooftops so like
what like what in new york would be
balling like the penthouse in some
building yeah there's that [ __ ] there's
that like like that billionaire like you
know all those international
billionaires coming to buy like 50
million dollars podcasting and standup's
going to get us there fellas no i don't
think so no that's tough i don't know
man like chrissy d lives in uh that's
not an island beautiful he has a great
hook
islands like you know that's the part
you're thinking like like where harry
osborne lived in spiderman well to me
staten island's like either you're a
family man or you're in the mafia yeah
there's no it's very it is it's very
like it's like it's very like big nice
houses there's a couple plumbers over
there too yeah a couple hvac guys yeah
if you want but if you want to live in
new york and have like
a three-bedroom
like place
you gotta be beyonce you gotta be
beyonce making
20 million dollars a year to own it yes
to own it yeah i mean to those houses
like you know those houses like down in
the village like a brownstone or
whatever it's like two stories or
whatever you guys want to stay millions
like 11 million but you guys want to
stay there well we don't know now i
don't know we were told we got that we
got the run down from timmy d we from
who
dylan yeah but you didn't do what though
timmy's smart was but that's what yeah
he was like you gotta start you know
prop real estate means we talk about
this all the time we were talking about
this this summer i can't really i mean
i've been in new york ten years i'm
really hating the the winners and now
that i have a couple of bucks i can't i
think we might uh relocate the whole oh
yeah right yeah uh we might relocate the
whole operation down to lake st pete or
like outside tampa just for the winter
nothing more natural just for a couple
more there's nothing more new york than
doing that that's hilarious of course i
would always have friends show new money
too yeah open up a hot dog
i always say i'm from new jersey but no
nothing is more jersey than living in
florida like nothing is more new jersey
than living in florida it's it's like
where everybody they just migrate
everybody my parents are talking about
we might buy a place in florida i love
tampa man
yeah
it's great
yeah get a pontoon boat or something for
a couple of months that's that's my
level that's what i think success is
getting caught up with the colombians
start running bam bam couple of
cigarette boats yeah
last break cats fans hopefully you're
enjoying this episode with the are you
garbage boys foley and kevin ufc 275 is
here and draftking sports book the
official sports betting
partner of the ufc has a heavyweight
offer for this weekend's fight with a
special parlay for all of our listeners
go ahead listeners and viewers listen
they're they're riding with your boy
here you're a thick friend they said
pick three fighters we're going to boost
the odds how would you pick dude i
picked gary in the main event against
glover texara he needs to get it done in
the first two rounds if he goes past two
it's gonna get a little dicey i think
glover's gonna grapple him price him in
the fourth or fifth so we need done the
first two rounds for ben on yerry then
you got chef chanko she wins she's
defends the most
times ever for a female fighter the most
title defenses ever she beats ronda
rousey if she wins that fight then he
got wayley wayley young jungchek is the
fight it's the co-main event that fight
is fantastic so you go to draftkings
sportsbook uh head to the app now under
the ufc page to check out brendan's
picks and bet on it and ride along with
him right now all customers can place a
same game parlay for saturday's fight
and if it hits
you'll double your winnings yes download
the draftking sports app right now use
promo code kats new customers can throw
down five dollars on ufc 275 and get 150
buckaroos and free bets instantly that's
code kats this saturday at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the ufc minimum age eligibility
restrictions apply seashell notes for
details how do you uh how did you guys
how did you blow up i'm in what happens
i want in on this ten percent mine was
late night eating
and the carbohydrates that is
how did it happen i think like looking
back at how it happened i think we had
been podcasting for like 10 years
together for like a hundred listeners
that nobody gave them like are you
garbage for ten years
we had a thing called the center city
comedy podcast and we had a thing called
hard feelings that we now just do that's
a whole nother show on our patreon so
we've been doing it together for 10
years and we're like we're really you
know you know we're very good together
working comics in the city trying to
come up and running around and then was
that we were tight with all these big
comments right the schultz is the gilles
because we were working comics in the
city but we just hadn't popped
uh and then the pandemic hit and we had
launched this
we had launched our garbage two weeks i
think we were two episodes in the
pandemic hit i was i remember i was
talking my wife i'm like i can't [ __ ]
this one can't fail as well like we just
she's doubled
yeah she's like of course she also moved
from germany
we started doing two episodes a week
because i'm like
well like we can start all these get
friends that we were with or all these
people around
zoom sitting around and i'm like hey you
wanna do the podcast like [ __ ] of
course i love you guys it would have
taken five years to get them all in
studio yes but like in a row i think we
went like norman soder schultz gillis
and like
that really started plus i think it's a
unique like you said it's unique yeah
it's unique yeah so people were like oh
this is [ __ ] cool
best time because again most podcasts is
just you know shooting the [ __ ] that's a
little different because we have
fanfiction in general like finding kid
or whatever it is just shooting the [ __ ]
non-stop so it's like when you get to do
something where there's like kind of a
um
not produce element but there's some
sort of theme or like underlying
fun yeah yeah it's yeah and another
thing we realized too especially when we
were doing them via zoom the questions
we asked are like stupid it's like you
know
what kind of
[ __ ] vacations did you go on what
kind of car did your mom drive like all
that kind of like did you drink milk
with dinner and we were getting these
stories that comics never told on stage
or on podcast before you know you're
going to a podcast you're like oh i'm
going to try to work in the [ __ ] call
with my pants down the hand job story
all that [ __ ] no one's asking if your
grandmother's patio had astro therapy
yeah we were getting you would see
comics be like i haven't thought about
this in 15 years 100 now they're telling
it and so it's like we were getting
different stories that yeah
like original organic like thoughts like
when i would those questions you asked
like [ __ ] i haven't talked about that
anymore yeah ten years which was not by
design like we realized afterwards
yeah my therapist knows but now you guys
know happiness the fruit loops in a bag
powder what's up daddy yikes let's do it
nick
so this is one of ours debate guys in
the [ __ ] shower jesus and that shower
is underground by oh man
that guy is subterranean at the moment
that has one of those storm things
around here yeah
holy [ __ ] what's up fellas
hope everything's good i hope you're
doing this
is this an isis video king interesting
for you guys
i just got out of the shower and i was
wondering
you go with that bar soap
[ __ ] body wash oh come on that barf
soap let you get in and out rub that
thing all over
set it down rinse it off and you're done
there's this guy's face
this guy's all perks for sure
anyways if he starts drowning a puppy i
would not be surprised all the way
anyways gang gang buzz buzz look forward
to hearing from you guys
um hopefully he's all wow
check on that guys
that's what this smells he's clean look
at the air vent look how small bro
he's like that's like that's like
airplane style yeah yeah yeah uh yeah
yeah or never body wash never really
borrowed yeah i'm still bar
yeah what's your ball i guess it's got
to be goat milk something yeah what is
your bar it has like the the the
charcoal no no i hate that [ __ ] actually
you're full of your skin and [ __ ] i just
[ __ ] have regular that's like lava
soap remember you know what that [ __ ]
would get it off yeah because kristen is
tattoos off she's like uh you should get
into like a routine where you have all
that and i'm like dude i i can't with my
with my ocd and then also like part of
me is like it's just kind of a scam like
you know there's uh
i can't believe you don't i thought you
would be all over this i'm not i'm not
people
yeah people think you look like a guy
takes baths but let me tell you
something though people think i love i
draw a knife
that's your thing i do a shower still
doing a nice bath we're too big for
baths we are too big for bats i don't
know why you gotta bring that
uh
you know what we do fit in though those
uh what are they called tiger foot
lions clubs what are they called lion's
feet eagles
tubs like the old ones oh the one you
see like
yeah i can slide into one of those yeah
i guess i couldn't yeah traditional
bathtub yeah no no i'm out i'm not as la
as people think i am that's the truth
do you have moisture on right now
moisturizer zero never have i ever done
it what's in
uh just product i just put product in
but then i wash it like every three days
what do you use like a pomade what were
you talking about uh i guess it would be
pomade i don't even really know you just
just
yep how much was that haircut
70 bucks what do you tip i'm surprised
that's low i'll give her a hundred
even hundred dollars 100 total 100 on
top 100 total yeah nice did she come to
the house and do it are you gonna throw
it in the place that's a good deal i
know why i go there because there's a
coffee shop next to it i get the coffee
you know me any time a place is i make
it near a coffee
was like 200 and they were doing it at
the house they do she's just sweetheart
i love her i assume you'd see gavin
newsom there when you're leaving no yeah
he has a he but he has another hair yeah
what do you pay for you probably you
probably get it like weekly or two yeah
when i would do like fades i'd go every
week especially if i'm going on the road
but i always wear a hat yeah so it's
like i'll get the sides that's about it
you know but a mexican cuts my hair for
twenty dollars right right right yeah
and he made it
yeah no problem he always makes me look
like his son
i don't uh i get my hair cut once every
two three months honestly yeah yeah we
get the long time i know yeah yeah yeah
what did we uh you same same [ __ ] what
chris like once every how long huh you
haven't had a cutting i've been growing
this for a while
i just started doing like you got to get
a shape nice haircuts like going like a
salon i go to the girl my girlfriend
goes to now nice i used to just go to
the dudes next door 15 bucks
that's where i'm at right now you never
know what you're gonna get it's wild
card yeah sometimes i don't like [ __ ]
leslie snipes you never watch it no but
i'm disgusting he's attractive no i know
i thought you would have like this whole
thing
you know i literally her friend makes it
or something like that yeah i literally
just use whatever soap is there and not
i scented i don't i don't do i make a
nice scent dude i like the flavor
you know shampoo conditioner body wash i
feel like i don't trust that [ __ ]
whatever you want man that's terrible
that's good yeah what's up chris brennan
and theo and everyone in the rick glass
uh would you rather
live forever or die right now jesus what
the [ __ ] whoa that's pretty deep you
just live for the rest of time
all you would have to pick live forever
die right now or live i don't know
that's probably hell though watch out
right hanks he touched the guy he's he's
like oh 800. he's old or something he
was doing okay though
he was pretty nice
like what about dude imagine being alive
in 3 000 years that's gotta [ __ ] 100
imagine watching all your friends and
family die yeah you watch everybody die
forever my personal answer is going to
be live forever what i want
i want to walk forever i want to watch
everyone die everyone friends and not
friends and then i want to make better
you know somebody get this guy a couple
deacons you know jesus you know how dope
your friends would be when you're like a
hundred two hundred four thousand years
old imagine the experience you're
dropping exactly
because nobody else is 4 000. you're
trying to hang out with hundreds
it doesn't matter dude think about your
stand up
3 000 years ago 4 000 years old 3 000
years from now yeah you guys don't get a
lot of people you guys don't remember
this but yeah
there was this guy named george clooney
go with me on this no everybody says
that
but all your friends and your loved ones
would all be gone dude yeah that would
suck but you're going to make [ __ ]
new friends you're going to have a new
family and you will be a [ __ ]
gazillionaire yeah yeah
and an end a wizard you'll be a wizard i
was just going to say actually i was
just going to say wizard i think you'd
be able to figure stuff out like right
when you meet people you'd be like i
know that i met this kind of guy a
hundred thousand thousand years ago yeah
you beat god no you'll be elon musk
but imagine how elon is not on the
spectrum but it could be real like
knowledge [ __ ] imagine if you were elon
musk though for and elon musk was four
thousand i mean are you kidding me in
four thousand years if elon musk was
still alive he would be jesus christ
sure he would be i mean that's a lot of
responsibility you want that off me
right now uh-huh
i can end all of my anxiety now imagine
having anxiety for the next four
thousand years
imagine they're dying right now oh no no
no
kids you don't have kids no yeah they
can't die
ambulance for this fat [ __ ] get him out
of here there's a chance he might die
right now anyway or at least throwing
the tape into this
yeah out of the four of us me and him
are going
i don't know what though i'm also not
very healthy i definitely wouldn't want
to die right now [ __ ] that no yeah
just starting to pop and you pass away
that's kind of romantic a little bit to
me the 27 club yeah we're past that but
i know but just like you like
i'd make one pretty good article i don't
like you know i don't like you know i
when i was a kid my parents listened
like the oldies and i would hear the
stories of like harry chapin or like jim
croci or like otis redding dying before
docks of the bay came out or whatever it
was that [ __ ] used to bug me out you're
getting ripped off [ __ ] that i'm going
wizard it's like heath ledger before
dark knight came out he wanted to knock
him out he was still getting bj's all
day long but yeah dude that's my thing
think dude four thousand years old dude
the stories you'd have with [ __ ] are
you kidding me yeah
but also do you keep looking older and
older and older you have to no your
bench have been button you look exactly
the same or do you stop at like you know
50. though they freeze you right now you
live forever right
if you stop at 50 i mean that's a
no-brainer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got to take that it's just a
platform interview with the vampire
right it's the same [ __ ] yeah
you're basically a vampire yeah
well you don't drink not man that was a
deep ass question to us yeah that really
rattled a
[Laughter]
great question this doesn't really fit a
category but just a pretty good question
hi guys my name is brooke and i'm from
new mexico i have a question for you
hottest girl new members do you have any
naughty teachers in school or maybe not
naughty but maybe they were into things
you didn't think that teachers would get
to
asking because i'm a teacher and i
recently ditched a day of school to see
theo in albuquerque yeah it was worth
going to sketchy albuquerque to cco live
but my students wanted to know why i was
gone for a day i told them that i had an
appointment out of town they bought it
but it got me wondering how many of my
teachers were playing hooky to do stuff
like that or weirder things so did you
have any naughty or weird teachers
growing up i'm a huge fan of all of
yours everything you do individually and
this podcast i love you all brandon eric
you're hilarious chris four years ago i
peed my pants watching one of your
netflix specials not kidding peed my
pants on my couch so like
with you two years ago i discovered theo
and i've been hopelessly in love ever
since anyway thank you guys for doing
what you do what a sweetheart
yeah i wish she was my [ __ ] teacher
my teachers looked like [ __ ] warlocks
yeah i gotta say i don't know it's like
a scumbag but my brain did not go to
playing hooky when she was throwing
naughty around 16 times no yeah i'm also
not missing class if she's my teacher no
[ __ ] my teacher mrs decker was [ __ ]
six ford yeah all mine were warlocks
yeah they were all warlocks dudes yeah
we had a substitute that was in playboy
seventh and eighth grade she'd roll in
every once in a while
like it'd be like moses how's that how
is that legal no internet how it's a
playboy exactly no internet no no
she did in her 20s but she was also an
actor she was in i think uh a movie with
john travolta called blowout not one of
his biggest boxers and that's probably
it if she's doing substitute teaching
yeah
yeah regional theater or whatever then
she got into teaching but dude i had a
teacher named mrs roach and she had
cancer sounds hot yeah
she was like clint eastwood dude she
[ __ ] she had cancer and she it's poor
lady she had can't in her nose so they
her nose is gone so she looked like the
the evil guy from stranger things with
it with the [ __ ] the skeleton strange
things four
times dude it was juice but it was like
wet and juicy but her nose is gone i
thought you're gonna say she was hot no
i [ __ ] [ __ ] i knew how i was just
such a thing and she would teach like it
was all good like your nose wasn't
missing does anyone know the question i
knows no
ah that's a tough one i remember i was
in the class i was in the classic story
that's how she that's how she looks
i'm talking back there that's mrs roach
she you know she was older she fell she
tripped over like the projection uh
productions
and then we just see her that's the
hardest thing i've ever seen being
carted out never saw her again
keep it light will you
you got disney coming in so the question
is do you guys think she's garbage
missing your
nose she's a cancer that's trash so all
right it was like wet in her face yeah
it was probably probably moist
we had a teacher who ended up he he was
post stroke
mr talon one side just hung over talon
and roach
these are some wild ass names sounds
like real sleazy lawyers though
we'll make her pay yeah yeah
um all right now have i i don't think
i've ever
i had a hot teacher in she was a science
teacher but i never everyone always was
like she's so hot and i never thought i
was like yeah she's all right but i
never really had a [ __ ]
never had a hot tv it's like when you
see the news or it's like teacher has
threesome with
seniors in high school and she's just a
[ __ ] dime piece like what [ __ ] yeah
high school is this these poor kids the
only thing that goes through my mind is
how the [ __ ] did anybody ever find out
about that when it's when it's a hot
girl and and guys well that's easy right
because the parents are like what's the
kid always on his phone and [ __ ]
going into that my friend
took that to the grave i don't know that
would have been like kennedy
i think it gets out you know
yeah you would tell people i guess
that's true
that comes out
yeah yeah you're at a house party
what you been up to dude mrs fields has
been sucking my head
what have you been up to
i've been [ __ ] mrs roach's nose hole
she won't stop calling
that's terrible it's time she's not
alive so that's all right all right
she's got people in new york hey guys my
name is mamie i'm from new mexico oh
you're not sorry if you can hear birds
i'm sitting outside
slight flex but i have a debate club for
you guys today
so
if you could choose any decade to be a
teenager throughout what decade would
you choose think about this all the time
great questions all the time yeah it's
wild to think about that all the time
the 60s baby great question the fashion
but why would i be hanging out
she said if you could be a teenager
because you're like growing no
responsibility i guess oh okay like a
fun time okay yeah
yeah
daddy the right answer because we live
now would be now because if we knew what
we knew now you'd go back to the [ __ ]
60s you'd be like what where's the
[ __ ] cable right you know that's
very true yes but if you didn't know
anybody the ignorance was bliss yeah out
of 70s seem pretty cool
a lot of drugs in the 70s but they were
snatching kids left and right yeah and
the serial killers during the 70s
then now though
not worse than now name one serial
killer
functioning right it seems yeah bro
there's a documentary being made about
him in 10 years we don't know them now
they're getting away it's kind of true
well you don't know we don't know dude
you know how the news would run with it
if there was another night stalker yeah
no i don't know i don't know but also
dna and all that stuff all that [ __ ]
that we had now makes it much harder for
them and there's cameras everywhere like
yeah yeah yeah it was scarier back then
way scarier don't get away with it so
you want a scary movie [ __ ]
struggling to throw on zodiac yeah yeah
yeah he's still on the loose daddy well
he's dead probably but yeah i'm sure
he's dead well we'll see i don't think
he's out there working stuff
that's true um yeah yeah you're right
though it was scarier in that respect
back then probably yeah it's also more
dangerous back then way more dangerous
even though we have all these mass
shooting stuff yes i wouldn't
imagine hitchhiking
people were dumb as [ __ ] back then dumb
as [ __ ] dude you know what's crazy but
if you go down to paying or go down pch
you'll see hitchhikers i'm like dude
you're nuts are you out of your [ __ ]
mind have you never seen a movie yeah
crazy yeah hitchhiker oh also where am i
gonna drive you [ __ ]
what are you talking about where are you
going santa barbara i'll drop you off
there and that's as far as i go you know
i'm not just saying that
i'll drop you off where i'm going and
then you're on your own like what the
[ __ ]
that's when you started you saw how that
ended too what did you say so that's how
rambo started and you saw how that
happened
oh yeah theo picks up hitchhikers and
films them goes instagram live jesus
he's there for the contest really in
hawaii
i don't know that's all probably a
little different i would assume it's a
little yeah was it somebody that looked
like theo and they were just like hey
what's up basically yeah yeah that's
okay good vibes jump in brother let's
roll yeah he's not going down skid row
picking up
that's a different animal hop in you
want something to do some of those
streets in la are dicey i got up early
this morning because i was jet lagged i
went to the 7-eleven
i was a block away i almost turned
around twice where are you staying well
where you are is there's like hollywood
uh yeah yeah yeah there's that
especially north hollywood
i saw a guy with a new tent this morning
outside like a brand new tent yeah he's
[ __ ] he's gotten rid of what he's got
he just patriot must be joking
who's doing his ad sales that's what i
want to know selling some merch somebody
like to see it man it's more females
than we've ever had thanks
on the show you know it's no big deal
hello king and the sting and the wing
and everybody in between
um i am staying up way past my bedtime
uh and i'm addressing
envelopes
to all of my um fellow graduates of
class of 2002 because we have our 20th
class reunion this summer
and i mistakenly ran for class president
my senior year so my question alert yo
you don't have to do that class reunions
are you going
are you not going is this a waste of
time nobody's going to show up
let me know you're the you're choosing
you're the class president yeah and in
20 years you're lying that's my
responsibility yeah steve office that's
a good person hey we're done
after four years though you know your
house is changed don't you don't have to
do that no one's going to be like linda
never [ __ ] said can you be can you
believe linda didn't get the [ __ ]
together organized that's [ __ ] nuts
um also are you have you guys go to your
region i never i haven't i didn't go to
my five my 10 or my 15.
i've been a loser through all of them
though yeah maybe
next one i might catch um
five ten
didn't do those
so my 20 year came up
uh however long ago was
three four years ago and um
i
i didn't want to go but i was mostly
friends with kids
the grade above me slight flex right but
but i was though and they thought and
they brewer and mahoney here
so they all told me that it it was
amazing theirs was amazing because i
didn't go to theirs right they're like
you gotta go it was
we all didn't want to go too
you're making a mistake you got to go
hold on i went to your five no i didn't
go to any of them because i [ __ ] go
to them i still keep in touch with two
of them but okay i don't care where did
you grow up la canada like near uh okay
the rose bowl right so
so i just didn't go because i don't know
i was probably on the road or some [ __ ]
but um they were like you gotta go
and she was like all right i'll go if
you say something i went and it was i
was like i should not have come yeah
like it was just kind of not fun
i i enjoyed seeing some of the people
but i also could text them and would
hang out with them and see them
individually anyway i'm big on like if i
wanted to see there's probably like four
people yeah outside of my circle that
would be like oh [ __ ] how you doing good
to see you there's some lights to it too
i don't want to [ __ ] course there's a
real sadness yeah like there's this one
kid who was a dime piece i mean he was
the king of those yeah yeah they're not
that they peaked then yeah that was the
best he's got and then i was uh last
time i was in denver i went to the
grocery store to pick up i don't know
whiskey or [ __ ] pepsi it was whiskey
yeah probably and i'm or nicotine but i
was walking around the [ __ ] uh aisles
of king supers and i see this guy in a
full [ __ ] sweatsuit and no no no nose
no no no no no no no
it was johnny roach
are you the one that [ __ ] my mom's
nose
we're sorry but dude i see this guy in a
matching sweat outfit which you should
probably shouldn't do and his guts out
to hair and in his hair he used to have
long gone like his hair's like [ __ ]
terrible
and then i and then finally i can see
he's following me i try to hey can i
help you with something i thought i was
like a fan of somebody goes bro come on
wow i'm not gonna say his real name but
yeah brian bowser blind blah blah
oh what's up dude holy [ __ ]
yeah been some tough years daddy you see
their face inside their face you're like
oh yeah it's like dog when you graduate
high school and if you stay
a lot of times in your town there's a
certain section of those people who age
like dogs right it's like if you're
posted up at the [ __ ] pub every
three days
you're just and they all become like
there's like you know a group of people
that stay from each year and then they
all just become awesome
there's like a 40 year old hanging out
with a 21 year old it's just and the 40
year old's wearing his letterman jacket
yeah exactly what are you doing people
have kids that [ __ ] sucks the life
out of people sure yeah that's also the
best thing but also
would i guess it could yeah it could
yeah like i'm talking getting up going
to work yeah you're like a [ __ ] roof
team having money
yeah fair point yeah i mean we tell dick
jokes you know so yeah right right
right but it's also weird like if you go
back to your high school reunion it's
like you have you can't relate to them
like what you've been doing they're
working nine to five and you're talking
about stand up you're you're patreon
that makes more money in a month than
they make in a year you know they say i
don't know man yeah that's great i would
like i said i would i would have been a
loser at every one like oh yeah i'm
still waiting tables he would have been
the guy like sean it's me
hey man remember the game against valley
where we put those enemies in tutorials
anyway can you pay my rent this month
i hate to do this dude i bumped into a
dude like right after i just moved to
new york chilean
that was a timely one
i had a dude who was like in uh oh man
that was great too you just missed three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's over dude
bro i can't i feel like i'm there daily
or just wherever you're doing a pocket
just with family with friends you're
like all right i'm not excited
you just went emergency
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
a son of a [ __ ]
should we let him go or no
oh you should let me tell the story then
played her that was that would have been
it
from north carolina and i have a king
here for you today
i am currently single and out in the
bars looking and my wing woman happens
to be my best friend my sister who's 33
and married her husband's not upon
browse upon her coming out with me and
my woman so i guess king are stinging it
coming out to the bars when you're
married
and shout out to you eric i love you
here he's not here i think um i think
that she seems friendly
right she seems like a [ __ ]
sweetheart she does she does this is the
problem i'll tell you right now she has
an ass on her tongue
this is the problem right now
but this is the problem though uh
don't go to the bars to look for
that's all yeah that makes sense that's
the thing because she's she's adorable
yeah yeah you're just meeting [ __ ]
you're meeting the [ __ ] guy that ran
into you and the [ __ ]
nike jumpsuit yeah yeah yeah you're
gonna be dirt bags at the ball yeah
where should she go like whole foods i
don't know [ __ ]
barnes and noble i mean
somewhere
somewhere but just walk around somebody
go to target
well no dudes get [ __ ] you know at
target yeah there's only weirdo
something like me looking at the toys or
something like that
it's me buying a three three-in-one body
wash
i thought she said wasn't that kind of
from the aspect of her sister's married
sister i mean yeah man i'm with him
it depends how many times this is going
on yeah
and also if she's like on the bar
[ __ ] dancing i'd be like all right
listen you're not you're not out there
for your sister really right her sister
goes the day before she's like i'm
scouting for you yeah exactly yeah yeah
i'm laying the groundwork for these
she's not even with you i had to check
out the
appetizers you gotta make sure she's
okay
because um
over a long time you know a longer
timeline eventually
something's gonna happen something
possibly could happen you know what i
mean could be two dudes that are perfect
whatever a couple of drinks are going
around people start making mistakes they
say you spend enough time in a barber
shop you end up getting your hair cut
you know what yeah that's going to
happen wow that's a great you should
make that good just make that up yeah
for sure
no it's an aaa thing i think yeah so my
uncle tells me
i don't know where do you go too
sorry to meet to meet uh like people i
mean yeah crazy issues
it's online yeah
i i just think i mean that's so enough
quality there though i don't know i
think so i'm not in a bar though right
yeah how's the bar different than dms
though so imagine do dmg is different
because you can shift through and like
figure out why in a bar there's [ __ ]
six dudes there and they're just like
hey
i mean what do you
maybe or the guy's the same thing he's
there then i don't want to be out man he
runs into hers it's broken
it wasn't the bar in star wars christ
it's in a nice place all right this
guy's uh what's up king instinct fan
everyone's morphing into the field no
these guys faces don't move college
baseball
[Music]
oh watching it oh no absolutely let me
know what y'all think gang gang fuzz
this guy's so bored yeah that's he sent
his submission was like [ __ ] it
was what was the question uh
it's the topic or like good or bad
watching college baseball baseball i
respect it i i have a tv outside hooked
up like that's pretty trashy yeah it's a
tough look
got a wall mount will you i have a glare
i want people to be playing for money
yeah otherwise i don't care really those
guys are trying to apply for money right
i know but it's like
you can't get contracts in a in a you're
they're playing in hopes of getting a
paycheck yes one day but mostly good
players are drafted from high school
yeah yeah i gotcha so these guys is oh i
see unless you're just a super bowl
right right right yeah i play for money
i want to see those guys play for you no
college football no college basketball
you don't watch any sports nope really
no i'll go to baseball games sometimes
because but with with my family and
stuff because they you know people are
like but baseball is boring i'm like
that's exactly why i want to go because
they take breaks and [ __ ] what about the
lakers game you don't go oh it's too
fast you don't watch any sports nothing
what's your joke what's your joke if you
get caught wearing another man's jewelry
yeah yeah yeah that's so weird yeah they
get to [ __ ] you that's so weird to have
a [ __ ] like lebron jersey on that's
another dude yeah especially as you get
older like it's
different but you know i don't wear a
player i just said the back's blank ever
since that's good yeah that's fine
that's good it'd be worse if you put
your name on it that's a bad luck too
that's that's even worse you pay for the
custom embroidery that's the best
yeah that's the best that's just sad
that's bad yeah things didn't work out
for you yeah the other day i was waiting
for this [ __ ] uh big boxing match on
espn
it says sorry the boxing match will be
aired after this college women's
softball game you're kidding me it's
like dude there's seven guys
what are we doing
wow he didn't play any sports in high
school or anything i played basketball a
little bit and then i was like what am i
going to do he did some jiu jitsu i did
he was in a theater class singing and
stuff there you go yep sing for him
well i could hit those mayo mayo maze
yeah do that mayo mayo you know what i
mean i could kill it but i don't
it's pretty good but my mom my mom every
time i even like do joking singing she's
like you know and i'm like ma
she was like you could have been i'm
like i made it yeah
but she's saying you could have been
like the next michael buble josh groban
yeah yeah
what plays did you do in high school
oh man do you remember
yeah i mean i did a lot of music look
over he's got a skull in his hand
no i didn't do those i did um little
shop hours at greece greece i did you
play danny no i played uh what yeah i
know yeah i play nikki you tried out for
danny though didn't you
i actually don't remember
you did foley played the car
i was thunder road i remember
i think maybe i maybe i won't i did
kenickie because
i wanted to not
he almost slipped into it right there
did you see this
because i didn't want because it's good
i don't know
when you play the lead you got to be
it's like so much work yeah you don't
want that
no i didn't get a lot of parts though
but he's like i didn't want to play the
lead man no no i didn't mind being one
of the pink ladies you know it's cool it
really makes me happy i just [ __ ]
what you were talking about like a gl it
was like glendale community college bro
it's not like i was in a [ __ ]
broadway
a really good actor and he did an
off-broadway play like not i mean this
was we were like really like still day
jobs and everything and he got this off
broadway play first of all it was the
big connecticut
it was like
dude he shows up i need him to do a spot
like we're both on the same show at a
club and he's literally
after the first day rehearsal i meet him
on the street in like [ __ ] april and
he's got a scarf around his neck i'm
like dude suck a [ __ ] dick that's
[ __ ] i'm not talking to you while you
have a skull take the scarf off i didn't
talk to you because i had to rest my
voice
[Laughter]
he just told me i thought it happened in
space the whole time i thought it was
set in space it was really just set in
like 2040 but that's how bad it was i
thought it was on another planet amazing
fellas we [ __ ] love you
this was a blessing yeah it was fun
uh we are all over the place we're going
to be in uh pittsburgh buffalo detroit
uh portland seattle what spots you play
like what kind of spots we just do
one-nighters at the club we're going
during the week like tuesdays
helium
helium yeah yeah i'm there this weekend
um yeah i love those heliums uh yeah
we're all over the place check it out
where can they get tickets um
[ __ ] at the
club i know but like a website uh we
don't have a website wow
wow these guys are mysterious yeah you
know what you send a self-addressed
stamp
i'm gonna be in it's a dallas place so
i'm gonna be in dallas and wichita uh
kansas
and lakeland florida i um i and now i'm
announcing today so chrisley.com and
then atlanta washington dc i'm gonna be
in uh
denver and a bunch of daddy got some big
theaters
yeah
i added another one at the wang that's
awesome in boston yeah all right be cool
man yeah well okay well i'm not chris i
will be in uh portland at the helium
this week thursday friday saturday
portland helium those tickets are damn
near sold out and then san francisco uh
cobbs comedy club is next week that's
friday saturday
two shows friday two shows saturday then
just added for the trash panda summer
tour fort wayne indiana july 14-16 san
diego california at the laugh factory
san diego great club i opened for you oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah your boys headline
this night club's awesome hats in the
heart of san diego that's july 21st
through the 23rd and then i end the
summer tour in baltimore august 4th
through the 6th tickets at thickboy.com
but portland i will see you this
thursday friday saturday love you guys
are you garbage boys kevin foley thank
you love you thank you so much keep
doing your thing man don't change we
love you guys we're out
[Music]
how many times i gotta make this song
hold on what is this now y'all wanna
switch
[Music]
wait a
minute it's the king and the sting and
the wing let's go
legendary trio bringing chris and theo
what you mean you know
you